now this is how you celebrate love with
a little extravagance in this luxury
bundle perfect for us earthlings we're
talking about opium's new luxury
spacewalker package
[Applause]
it's fine it's fine you're doing great
captain you are making me blessed you're
gonna you sure we're all we're all doing
our best this luxury space roller
package and here to tell us more about
the astronomical details is the
commander of the starship opm73 captain
identify herself thank you very much i
am the uh captain of the starship opm
seven three amadeus coonan and it is
my great pleasure and your great
pleasure
uh to have me here it is my great
pleasure i mean here we go it's summer
it's all about to happen you've been in
the house for a long time you're
thinking i haven't gone in a rolls royce
anywhere and you can now do that you can
come and see us we're going to feed you
it'll be a show it'll be a whole thing
this is a vip experience like i've never
even heard of first of all let's talk
about the show opium which you are a
part of a great show at the cosmopolitan
tell us a little bit about this
so if you imagine that
the rocky horror picture show sort of uh
met with
circa 1960 star trek and made a
beautiful little love child that is us
that is that that is us it's very rude
very raucous very fun
very intimate tiny little stage you're
right up in the action so you get to see
everything up close you know it ain't
the circus unless you're scared yeah and
you are putting together a package where
you can have a rolls-royce pick you up
dinner and the show talk to us about
this vip experience
okay so you know
we were thinking we had to sort of up
the game yeah
so
we've got the the space roller that'll
come and get you to your house it'll
drive right up there we take you from
your house we pick you up we carry you
literally like you're the infant into
the car
you're driven to the show you can eat at
private little dining rooms in super
frico in our incredible restaurant
alongside the show you can sit at a
private booth you can watch the show we
do photos it's a whole thing
and and super freako tell us a little
bit about the restaurant what kind of
food do we have here super freako is as
we would say psychedelic american
italian
really
excellent like uh the the consultant
chef there anthony falco has put
together this excellent menu there's
entertainment and stuff happening all
the time while you're eating the drinks
from leo robocheck up out of this world
we've got the ski lodge which is a
little secret bar attached which is
incredible it's
i i think it's one of the most exciting
things happening on this trip at the
moment it's a good time
i mean vip all the way and how do people
become a part of this experience i mean
i'm i'm ready to sign up everyone should
have a flare under the seat
of their lounge chair at home you simply
fire that flare into the air we will see
it
and we will come and get you
jump online go to opium.com i think we
are you can go through the cosmopolitan
you can go through spiegelworld's
website all the details are there put
yourself in indulge enjoy alabanza any
chance for a parade come on let's do it
and you are seriously one of the
funniest people like we don't even know
each other yet it gets better i know and
you're just on afternoon television i
can't imagine what you're saying it's
not even four o'clock at night it's very
different
it's very different
i i can't wait to see go check out the
cosmopolitan this is this is really one
of the most luxurious opium launching
this new luxury space roller package you
got to check it out thank you so much
thank you i'll never forget you
coming up